AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE GET THE
FINAL SAY.
THE CHOICE FOR PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO BE CLEAR.
HERE WITH REACTION, LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
SENATOR, HOW ARE YOU?
>> I AM GREAT.
THAT WAS WELL DONE.
THANK YOU.
>> SEAN: I GOT A GOOD GRADE IN
MY CLASS.
NONE OF THIS IS UPSETTING IN TH
LEAST TO ME BECAUSE THIS IS WHO
THEY ARE.
THIS DEFINES THEM.
THIS REPRESENTS EVERYTHING THEY
HAVE DONE FOR THREE YEARS.
CAN YOU NAME ONE ACCOMPLISHMENT
BESIDES THIS IF THEY WANT TO
CONSIDER THIS AN ACCOMPLISHMENT?
AND ACT LIKE THEY ARE NOT
HIGH-FIVING.
FULL.
THAT IS MORE BOLD TO.
>> HERE IS THAT.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
THE REASON THEY ARE DOING THIS
IS NANCY PELOSI WOULD LOSE THEI
JOBS IF THEY DIDN'T MOVE TOWARD
IMPEACHMENT.
WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN MARCH AND
NOW.
IMPEACHMENT SHOULD BE A GRAVE
DECISION MADE IN A BIPARTISAN
MANNER.
WHAT HAPPENED IS THE MOB TOOK
OVER THE HOUSE.
THE MOB IS RUNNING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IF SHE DID NOT MOVE TO IMPEACH
THIS PRESIDENT, SHE WOULD NOT B
SPEAKER.
SHE PICKED HER JOB OVER WHAT'S
GOOD IN THE COUNTRY AND I HOPE
AT THE END OF THE DAY IT COST
THE DEMOCRATS THE HOUSE AND IT'
GOING TO DO A LOT TO REELECT TH
PRESIDENT.
THEIR GOAL TO INS DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BLOW UP I
THEIR FACE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT THE
JUDICIARY WOULD LOOK LIKE WITH
FOUR MORE YEARS OF DONALD TRUMP?
>> YES.
HE.
HE IS APPOINTING A LOT OF JUDGES
.
WE HAVE ONE FACT WITNESS, EVERY
OTHER WITNESS WAS A HEARSAY
WITNESS OR AN IVORY TOWER
PERFORMER PROFESSOR.
MY QUESTION IS IT GOES TO THE
SENATE.
MITCH McCONNELL HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR AND YOU HAVE BEEN VERY
CLEAR, SOME HAVE ASKED ME ON
RADIO AND TV, THEY WRITE ME.
WHAT ABOUT ROMNEY.
WHAT ABOUT SUSAN COLLINS IN
MAINE WHICH I THINK NEEDS THE
PRESIDENT SUPPORTS.
WHAT ABOUT LISA RUTKOWSKI, OR I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO ELSE.
>> HERE IS WHAT I THINK.
I THINK REPUBLICANS ARE GOING T
BE VERY ELECTED TO LEGITIMIZE
WHAT THE HOUSE DID BECAUSE IF
YOU CARE ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AN
THE INSTITUTION, WHAT THEY DID
IN THE HOUSE AS A THREAT TO THE
PRESIDENCY.
THEY STARTED IN THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
IT WAS HEARSAY UPON HEARSAY
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
ALLEGEDLY LEAKING INFORMATION.
THE ONLY ACTUAL FACT WITNESS
EXONERATED THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS THE FIRST IMPEACHMENT
DONE BY PARTISAN POLITICIANS.
EVERY OTHER IMPEACHMENT HAS BEE
DRIVEN BY OUTSIDE COUNSEL
SPENDING TIME AND MONEY LOOKING
INTO ACCUSATIONS THAT RESULTED
IN CRIMINAL LIABILITY.
BILL CLINTON COMMITTED A CRIME,
DONALD TRUMP IS DONE NOTHING
WRONG.
I THINK IT WILL BE DIFFICULT FO
REPUBLICANS TO LEGITIMIZE WHAT
THE HOUSE DID.
>> I AGREE.
SO, LET'S ASSUME YOU'VE GOT A
HOUSE MEMBERS I GUESS, HOWEVER
THEIR TEAM IS'S, THEY WILL
PRESENT THEIR CASE AND THEN WHA
HAPPENS?
>> HERE IS WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THIS NEEDS TO LOOK AT THE
SUPREME COURT ARGUMENT PRAYED
OUR HOUSE COLLEAGUES ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
JORDANS, MEADOWS, GUESTS,
RADCLIFFE DID A GREAT JOB
EXPOSING THIS SHAM, BUT WHEN WE
COME TO THE SENATE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF TH
UNITED STATES PRESIDING OVER TH
TRIAL.
THIS NEEDS TO BE PRESENTED TO
THE SENATE REASONABLY AND
RATIONALLY BASED ON FACTS AND
LAW.
I HOPE THE PRESIDENT WILL PUT A
LEGAL TEAM TOGETHER THAT CAN
TEAR THIS CASE APART FACTUALLY
AND LEGALLY.
WE ARE GOING TO ACQUIT THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK IT WILL BE BIPARTISAN
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER AND TH
POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES TO THIS
WILL BE FELT IN THE NEXT
ELECTION.
PLAY THIS TAPE ON ELECTION NIGHT
.
I WILL MAKE A PREDICTION HERE,
THE IMPEACHMENT OF THIS